Hélène buzetti Jonathan Trudeau
Christian Dufour bonsoir bonsoir congrès
de la CAQ et vote de confiance monsieur
Legault
regaillardi par un
98,6 a dit je ne suis pas prêt de m'en
aller de ne partez pas ces rumeurs on
écoute un très court extrait
de réfléchir sur la relève ce que j'ai
dit puisque je répète deux conditions
pour que je sois candidat en 2026 sentir
l'appui de la population peut être en
santé
Jonathan vous étiez au Congrès est-ce
que vous avez rencontré les neuf ou dix
personnes sur 1000 qui ont pas donné
leur confiance au chef
ces personnes-là se faisait plutôt
discrète parce que si on pensait qu'il y
aurait peut-être un peu d'insatisfaction
bon les dernières semaines qui ont été
plus difficiles peut passer au dos
évidemment le dossier du troisième bien
je dois vous dire qu'on était plus dans
une dynamique de parler de troisième
mandat que de 3e lien il y a pas les
militants ont mis ça derrière eux il y a
à peu près personne qui parlait de ça
quoi que faut pas chercher bien loin
pour trouver des élus et des employés
politiques qui bon à mon couvert vont
dénouer dénoncer son vœu la gestion
chaotique de ce dossier là mais du côté
des militants ils sont contents ils ont
fait rire 90 députés il y a quelques
mois de ça et je pense que François
Legault était beaucoup plus confortable
et heureux d'être dans cette arène là
que lorsqu'ils lorsqu'il est à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est semaine si
il a des journées pas mal plus difficile
donc ça a été ça a été une bonne fin de
semaine pour François Legault alors
Hélène ça nous rappelle que les
militants d'un parti quand on leur amène
une grosse victoire électorale c'est
quand même l'essentiel de la joue de
politique là ils sont contents
en même temps il y a peut-être pas pas
nécessairement de corrélation je pense à
Jean Charest en 2008 qui après avoir
perdu sa majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale avec quand même récolté un
confortable
97.2% je crois si ma mémoire est bonne
alors comme quoi des fois il y a une
quand même une certaine déconnexion
entre l'appui des militants de partie et
l'appui de la population mais je pense
que ce que ça démontre cette absence de
contestation ou de grenouillage
quelconque malgré que la cacahu quand
même des semaines difficiles
dernièrement ça démontre que la fin des
la fin des partisans et c'est parti
politique dans lesquels il y a des gens
très très impliqués très très convaincus
qui s'impliquent il y en a de moins en
moins et bien souvent c'est surtout de
nature à causer des pépins et aux
parties je pense aux parties
conservateurs qui à cause d'une base
militante très radicale n'est pas
capable de se recentrer monsieur le goût
lui il a toujours il s'en est jamais de
s'adresser au centre mou la majorité
silencieuse appelée là comme vous voulez
des gens qui ne s'impliquent pas
nécessairement dans des partis
politiques alors
le Congrès et le reflet de ça on ne voit
pas beaucoup de gens qui militent se
sont beaucoup des apparatifs et ça nous
donne les résultats que l'on a vu avec
des résultats quasi staliniens
est-ce que ça vous a surpris ou pas
vraiment ce score non pas du tout je
trouve c'est dans la nature des choses
ce résultat-là pour trois raisons je
dirais tout d'abord que parce que pour
la carte que monsieur Legault c'est pas
un chef comme les autres c'est le chef
fondateur donc un statut peut
particulier peut aussi être n'est pas un
parti très idéologique le silence c'est
c'est
le pouvoir donc je pense que moi je
m'attendais à ça surtout que là ça va
pas bien pour laque donc sultan serrer
les les ça va être souvent c'était
fonctionnel de faire les reins puis pas
en fait de prétendants avéré ou révéler
monsieur Lego donc tout en fait aller
vers de plus de plébiscitiste en faveur
de Monsieur Lego ça veut pas dire que il
y a pas des gens dans la CAQ qui pensent
mutuellement que ça peut être effet
correctement il y a pas des gens qui
sont critiques mais ce qui est arrivé en
fait semaine je pense que c'était dans
la nature des choses et on sert à les
rendre quand ça va mal en politique
c'est pas le temps de commencer à tirer
sur le chef aussi et Monsieur Lego je
veux faire entendre cette extrait qui
dit en fait les Québécois parce que lui
a grandi le cercle pas juste les
délégués qui étaient là mais dit les
Québécois comprennent qu'on doit changer
de décision des fois quand le contexte
dit-il change en écoute
je pense que il y a une majorité de
Québécois qui comprennent puis qui même
souhaitent que quand une situation
change mais qu'on change nos solutions
c'est ce que j'essaie de faire c'est ce
que j'ai fait pendant la pandémie je me
suis pas obstiné à défendre
l'indéfendable quand la situation évolue
ben il faut aussi que les solutions
évoluent c'est ce que j'essaye de faire
je pense les Québécois comprennent
Jonathan quand même sur la rive-sud de
Québec là ils doivent coupe de personnes
qui comprennent pas encore tout à fait
là
c'est important de faire la nuance parce
que si on a l'impression que les
militants de la CAQ ont mis de côté
toute l'histoire le cafouillage
entourant le troisième bien ou que les
militants satisfaits ne sont juste ne se
sont juste pas pointés à Sherbrooke qui
en demeure pas moins puis je prends le
pouls à tous les jours j'en ai une
émission de radio à Québec les gens ils
sont pas fâchés Patrice ils sont
carrément engagés encore il ne
décollèrent pas parce qu'il y a la
décision elle-même et il y a le fait la
façon de l'avoir gérer l'absence
d'excuse le faux prétexte sur les temps
de passage plutôt que de parler de la
réalité de l'augmentation des coûts etc
absolument et François Legault je pense
est suffisamment habile et intelligent
pour comprendre que là ça vient
confirmer évidemment son son assise sa
main mise sur son parti sur son cocus
sur son conseil des ministres mais il ne
doit pas négliger le fait qu'en ce
moment il a un passage plus difficile
dans la population que ça il doit que ça
se stabilise rapidement et là on est
Christian sur le même sujet c'est-à-dire
le 98 doit pas lui faire oublier qu'il y
a des défis réels dans chez les
électeurs Christian non je pense qu'il
le sait très bien que ça laisse le
grosse trace c'est la plus grande crise
que son gouvernement traverse depuis
qu'il a été élu puis une espèce de
désamour profonde à la grande région de
Québec mais il reste qu'en fin de
semaine c'était quand même important que
les troupes se resserrent autour de leur
chef parce que justement à ça va pas
tellement bien mais je me suis le goût
je pensais très conscient de ça je pense
que tout le monde est conscient de ça il
s'est passé quelque chose dans le
dossier du troisième lien à Québec en
défaveur de la carte qui se prend un
hasard si Monsieur Lego désormais le
parti qui l'attaque prioritairement
c'est pris avec solidaire c'est plus les
libéraux c'est le Parti québécois parce
que c'est le Parti québécois qui semble
avoir profité de ça ouais dans le
dernier sondage les GNN oui ben en fait
je pense que monsieur Legault a raison
de dire que les Québécois sont capables
de comprendre qu'un politicien change de
position à mesure que la situation
évolue la question est pas là c'est que
les Québécois ont bien réalisé que la
situation par rapport au troisième bien
va pas vraiment évoluer depuis la
campagne électorale c'est qu'on avait un
peu caché les faits pour aller chercher
des votes dans la grande région de
Québec pour ne pas se faire voler
peut-être quelques sièges par le Parti
conservateur qui autrement aurait surfé
sur ce sujet du troisième lien alors
c'est ça que les Québécois ne digèrent
pas pourtant le changement de position
qui par ailleurs et beaucoup plus aligné
avec la position d'une majorité de
Québécois entre certainement à
l'extérieur de la région de Québec
Simon je l'ai barré est-il dans quelle
mesure il est beaucoup un peu moyen
d'aller on va écouter un de ses Scrum en
fin de semaine ou il reconnaît qu'il
n'en n'avait pas parlé au Premier
ministre du fait une des nominations
c'était son ami on écoute
ça arrive quelquefois depuis que je suis
ministre de la Justice depuis presque
trois ans
ça doit être arrivé environ peut-être 5
fois je vous dirai
est-ce que
quand ça va être à refaire est-ce que
vous allez avoir une attitude pour
activer et analyser le Conseil des
ministres le Premier ministre que vous
connaissez la personne très certainement
monsieur Lacroix suite aux deux derniers
jours dans l'éventualité où la même
situation se représenterait
effectivement suite à l'expérience que
nous avons vécu je soulignerai
Jonathan il dit je vais d'abord y
reconnaît que à cinq reprises il n'a pas
pris les recommandations du Comité il a
dit refaites vos devoirs etc et est-ce
que est-ce que il est profondément ou
pas d'après vous dans l'embarras avec
cette histoire là
il est embarrassé
qu'on vient d'entendre ça c'est le Scrum
qui le fait dimanche j'ai l'impression
que c'est un peu saisi mais le somme qui
le fait samedi à son arrivée au Congrès
on pouvait prendre la mesure de quel
point il était et branler par ça
sincèrement bien que je ne mets
aucunement doute son sens de de
l'intégrité sa bonne foi il n'a que lui
à blâmer parce que c'est son imprudence
qui l'a conduit là je le crois là que le
processus il a été respecté tel qu'il
est écrit tel qu'il est prévu etc mais
quand c'est moi j'en ai barré de samedi
par exemple nous dit je savais bien que
ça ferait des vagues en nommant mon ami
juge mais si tu te doutes que ça va
créer des vagues comment se fait-il que
tu as pas le réflexe d'avertir le
cabinet du premier ministre d'avertir
tes collègues autour de la table donc
là-dessus je pense que il a commis une
imprudence il empile maintenant on a
appris dans les toutes dernières minutes
que la commissaire à l'éthique va
déclencher une enquête évidemment c'est
pas agréable de savoir que la la comme
ça on va faire en quête mais je pense
de façon plus prudente que monsieur
Simon j'avais m'arrête le fait Hélène
oui en fait moi de son cabinet de
Monsieur Janet barrette me dit que
c'était une quatre finalement que le
chiffre 4 sur à peu près 70 nominations
pas que c'est super important on peut
pas nous dire pourquoi dans ces cas-là
il n'a pas suivi la recommandation mais
certains des scénarios qui existent
c'est par exemple si le comité n'arrive
pas à faire des recommandations et ça
c'est une possibilité parce que parfois
il n'y a pas assez de candidats ou les
candidats ne sont il y en a aucun qui
sait qualifiés et je pense que si
j'avais à faire une comparaison entre
les systèmes de Québec et le système
d'Ottawa il est peut-être là-dessus
c'est le fait que dans les deux cas il
faut bien inciter là-dessus il y a des
comités indépendants qui font des
courtes listes qui sélectionnent des
gens qui sont jugés compétents et donc
dans les deux cas on a toujours des
personnes qui sont jugées compétentes
pour être juges mais à Québec on fait un
concours pour chat à chaque fois qu'un
poste de juge s'ouvre alors
techniquement il y a 15 20 postes qui
souffrent dans une année quelqu'un un
avocat qui aurait envie de devenir juge
devrait appliquer 15 ou 20 fois
Ottawa on procède différemment on
analyse toutes les demandes pour de gens
qui veulent devenir juge à peu près une
fois par une à deux fois par an et
lorsque qu'elle et on fait un bassin et
quand il y a un poste précis qui s'ouvre
on contacte la juge un chef pour dire
quels sont les compétences qu'on a
besoin pour ce poste précis et on pige
dans le bassin et comme ça on n'a pas de
situation où on se retrouverait avec une
liste insuffisante pour un poste
particulier
que la nomination sur la côte nord où on
semble lui reprocher en fait d'avoir
fait nommé des gens qui étaient pas de
la côte de la région
c'est ça qui fait plus mal pierre
pollièvre qui estime que si Justin
Trudeau a fait modifier le passeport
canadien avoir des images en enlevant
Vimy en enlevant des d'autres terriforx
donc des éléments de l'histoire
canadienne c'est qu'il veut abolir
l'histoire pour que l'histoire commence
avec lui le nouveau héros ça c'est la
thèse monsieur poignet envoyer en vidéo
qui est en anglais je vous fais entendre
un extrait
est-ce que je commence avec vous
Christian est-ce que Justin Trudeau a
voulu biffer l'histoire en enlevant des
éléments de l'histoire parce que dans le
nouveau passeport sachez que plutôt que
j'ai mis du seuil il y a effectivement
des écureuils et des flocons de neige
très intéressant je me lance on n'est
pas en train d'assister à un mouvement
de la part de pierre poilliev sur le
plan
identitaire qu'on devrait surveiller
parce que jusqu'à présent il y a
beaucoup en fait parler d'économie en
fait du mode de vie des Canadiens qui
souffrait moi je rattache ça avec sa
prise de position le sur l'initiative du
siècle en matière d'immigration c'était
juste un passeports ce serait pas grave
c'est vrai que les passeports ont été
complètement neutralisés on a enlevé les
symboles
identitaires canadiens mais ça se
rattache à quelque chose de beaucoup
plus large dont le gouvernement Trudeau
est porteur une espèce de volonté de
dénationaliser le Canada le Canada en
fait c'est un pays qui accueille
l'ensemble le reste de la planète comme
si ils ont un peu le rêve de son père
puis avec le Trudeau qui se voyait un
citoyen du monde donc je
que ça soit un nouveau filon que Pierre
poilue va utiliser le domaine du
dentaire et dans le reste du Canada ça
semble toucher les gens on avait
l'impression souvent que c'était juste
juste au Québec que ça pouvait marcher
donc moi c'est chose pour surveiller ça
c'est important puis la vidéo il est
très bon le vidéo dessus
d'ailleurs ils ont fait des questions
avec ça depuis mercredi dernier il est
consommateurs
peut-être que il pense que ça peut les
aider notamment avec les partiels qui
s'enviennent il y a un côté où Maxime
Bernier se présente ça pourrait
peut-être être un peu chaud une ancienne
circonscription qui a déjà été
conservatrice mais qui était devenu
libéral si Monsieur Pollier vous
performe bien il pourrait peut-être
espérer à vivre donc peut-être que il
veut faire des points avec ça mais il
faut quand même se rappeler quelque
chose Patrice là c'est que là on accuse
les libéraux de faire quelque chose que
eux-mêmes les conservateurs ont fait ce
passeport il avait été changé en 2012
par le gouvernement conservateur de
Steven Harper auparavant je suis allé
vérifier dans mes précédents passeport
ce n'était que des feuilles d'érable et
c'est avec monsieur Harper qu'on a lancé
cette grande entreprise de construction
patriotique on mettait la reine partout
et là on s'est dit on va on va se draper
dans notre histoire en mettant toutes
sortes de symboles oui mais il y a 8000
mais il y a aussi du pétrole des choses
comme celle-là et même à l'époque il y
avait eu des critiques on disait c'est
pas assez diversifié il y a pas assez de
femmes justement trop de place au
pétrole alors il faut quand même
je sais pas parce que c'est une bataille
culturelle entre les deux parties
ok Jonathan cette conclusion
ça ça tombe dans la catégorie du
Meilleur une vidéo qui est bien fait le
bon ton n'est pas sur ces grands chevaux
et il a un filon qui est intéressant
c'est à dire oui les conservateurs sont
en faveur du multiculturalisme mais ce
qui veut pas dire qu'on doit effacer la
fierté canadienne et là-dessus je pense
qu'il a il a quelque chose qui va
exploiter va continuer à cogner sur ce
clou là je pense qu'on va entendre
beaucoup beaucoup parler dans les
prochaines semaines prochaines mois
t'intéressais donc vous voyez Christian
c'est intéressant on va suivre ça à vous
trois merci beaucoup bonne soirée c'est
terminé au revoir au revoir